Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This incredible paper promises procedural
and physically-based rendering of glittering
surfaces.
Whoa.
Okay, I am sold… provided that it does as
well as advertised.
We shall see about that!
Oh, goodness, the results look lovely.
And now, while we marvel at these, let’s
discuss what these terms really mean.
One, physically-based means that it is built
on a foundation that is based in physics.
That is not surprising, as the name says so.
The surprise usually comes when people use
the term without careful consideration.
You see, light transport researchers take
this term very seriously, if you claim that
your model is physically-based, you better
bring your A-game.
We will inspect that.
Two, the procedural part means that we ourselves
can algorithmically generate many of these
materials models ourselves.
For instance, this earlier paper was able
procedurally generate the geometry of climbing
plants and simulate their growth.
Or, procedural generation can come to the
rescue when we are creating a virtual environment
and we need a hundreds of different flowers,
thousands of blades of grass, and more.
This is an actual example of procedural geometry
that was created with the wonderful Terragen
program.
Three, rendering means a computer program
that we run on our machine at home and it
creates a beautiful series of images, like
these ones.
In the case of photorealistic rendering, we
typically need to wait from minutes to hours
for every single image.
So, how fast is this technique?
Well, hold on to your papers, because we don’t
need to wait from minutes to hours for every
image.
Instead, we need only 2.5 milliseconds per
frame.
Absolute witchcraft.
The fact that we can do this in real time
blows my mind, and, yes!
This means that we can test the procedural
part in an interactive demo too!
Here we can play with a set of parameters,
look, the roughness of the surface is not
set in stone, we can specify it and see as
the material changes in real time.
We can also change the density of microfacets,
these are tiny imperfections in the surface
that really make these materials come alive.
And if we make the microfacet density much
larger, the material becomes more diffuse.
And if we make them really small…ohoho!
Loving this.
So, as much as I love this, I would also love
to know how accurate this is.
For reference, here is a result from a previous
technique that is really accurate, however,
this is one of those methods that takes from
minutes to hours for just one image.
And here is the other end of the spectrum,
this is a different technique that is lower
in quality, however, in return, it can produce
these in real time.
So which one is the new one closer to?
The accurate, slow one, or less accurate,
quick one What?!
Its quality is as good as the accurate one,
and it also runs in real time.
The best of both worlds.
Wow!
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect, the fact that this particular example
worked so well is great, but it doesn’t
always come out so well.
And, I know, I know, you’re asking, can
we try this new method.
And the answer is a resounding yes, you can
try it right now in multiple places!
There is a web-demo, and it was even implemented
in Shadertoy.
So, now we know what it means to render procedural
and physically-based rendering of glittering
surfaces in real time.
Absolutely incredible.
What a time to be alive!
And if you enjoyed this episode, we may have
two more incredible glint rendering papers
coming up in the near future.
This, and this.
Let me know in the comments below if you would
like to see them.
Write something like, “yes please!”.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!